president biden said no one was better
qualified to take charge of the influx
of unaccompanied migrant children than
his vice president
and he pointed out that this was the
role he took under president obama when
he was vice president
one of the ways we learned is that if
you deal with the problems in the
country
it benefits everyone kamala harris laid
out several areas of focus
i look forward to engaging in diplomacy
with a government with private sector
with
civil society and and the leaders of
each in el salvador
guatemala and honduras to strengthen
democracy
but the mere fact that once again a vice
president is being tasked with this role
is raising questions about whether
harris will really be bringing
new thinking to the issue of migration
or will stick to strategies that clearly
haven't worked in the past
regional development isn't something
that you can switch a light on and off
it's going to take time it's going to
take effort and it's going to take years
of sustained development
so while what vp harris is doing might
pay off in the long run
in the short term the more important
thing is going to be to surge resources
to the border
to handle the arriving families and
children safely and humanely
the biden administration is being given
credit for speeding up the processing of
child migrants who began entering the
country in november
when a court forced the trump
administration to relax its blanket ban
on undocumented migration but only for
unaccompanied children
a highly choreographed tour of a
facility in karizo
springs texas was arranged for one u.s
network
and then distributed to the rest of the
media on wednesday the footage showed
uncrowded spaces the reporter on the
tour wasn't allowed to speak to any
children
four hundred kilometers south here in
donner texas at the border we know
circumstances are different this
facility is
overflowing with unaccompanied children
on sunday it was fifteen hundred percent
over capacity
there are many reasons why march is on
track to see a record seventeen thousand
unaccompanied undocumented children
enter the us at the southern border
not least the normal seasonal increase
in migration in the spring
that this year has been supplemented
because donald trump closed the border
between march and november of last year
but migrant groups say there's plenty of
blame to go round for the current chaos
and distress
starting with successive governments
both democratic and republican
that have spent an estimated 55 billion
dollars over the last 12 years
on what's referred to as the border
industrial complex
high-tech equipment and militarization
at the border instead of investing
in humane facilities to shelter and
process
the yearly flow of undocumented migrants
that streams to the border nonetheless
shia britancy al jazeera donna texas